but I think that it's some genuine
concern in Scotland and indeed not just
in Scotland and Wales of Northern
Ireland we hope that what we would have
would be a four-nation consensus and in
effect what we see tonight is the Prime
Minister has broken that consensus
there's a divergence of nee messages are
we being delivered and I and my part in
my government that Ed nur regret that
because our message is a very simple one
it's a clear one and that is that people
should be staying at home to protect the
NHS and to save lives and I think what
we got tonight is confusion has just
been shown by your own reporters their
businesses are going to be concerned at
end of the day mark the absolute
priority for all of us should be about
saving lights we haven't got the our
number down to a level that would
indicate to us that we should be
allowing more people to go back to work
at this stage and indeed in Scotland the
guidance that we have given to the
construction industry unless they were
working on hospital projects for example
is that construction activity shouldn't
be taking place and the same goes for
manufacturing if it was only for the
food industry essential industries that
should be at work so we do have a
situation tonight that the devolved
administration's are in a very different
place from the government in London